damn lag man that's not true and no one  has ever said that look the reason I'm  running is because I've been around a  long time I'm not more than most people  and I can get things done that's why I'm  running and you want to check my shape  on let's do push-ups together man let's  do this run  [Applause]  not only Guinness said my son as done in  the wrong line did not let any occasion  and no word has ever said it I just said  I setup my son to work in an auto  company didn't know what you said I had  to work straitjackets NBC you did not  hear that what you heard look okay I'm  not gonna hit it hard but look here's  the deal here's the deal  [Music]  any other questions  you